the virtual high street is just such an
amazing tool to find out
what sudbury has to offer from pubs and
cafes and restaurants to the library
you know if you're not one for internet
shopping then it's perfect just to see
what we've got and then maybe take a
trip
out and enjoy welcome to sudbury's
virtual high street
so i'm sarah and i'm from ducking boots
and um
we operate a shop like this one um
with outlets lots of small businesses
and we also operate the two pop-up
shop units out the front helping
businesses to connect with local
customers
starting any business is a really tricky
decision to make the further we went
into renovating our little shop
the more it was becoming clear that a
lockdown was going to be
inevitable
spring summer stock had just arrived so
the shop was full of spring
summer i was a bit concerned that you
know i might get stuck with a load of
stock
during lockdown we set up a website so
we could start loading
the product online helping local people
in sudbury to discover and shop local
providing convenience choice and
flexibility
discover fantastic local businesses on
your doorstep
i've been looking online for quite a
long time and then thinking oh i won't
be able to do that
so i'm sure if i we can do it anyone can
do it
my message to the locals that have
supported us through the lock down and i
suppose supported all of the businesses
through sudbury is just thank you so
much it's meant the world to us it's
meant
the difference between opening our doors
at the end of all of this and not
opening our doors
after the lockdown it was it was busy it
was lovely
the markets are amazing and i think the
market saw a lot of people through
lockdown it's a really beautiful little
market town